for you and health and care secretary
matt
hancock has just given a statement in
the last few moments
um he says i accept that i breached the
social distancing guidance
in these circumstances i have let people
down
and i am very sorry i remain focused on
working to get the country
out of this pandemic and would be
grateful
for privacy for my family on this
personal matter okay let's go straight
to sam coates
um who can talk to us about this
statement
clearly uh matt hancock saying he's
sorry sam but he
seems to say that he's staying in his
position for now so i think what we read
into this statement is that matt hancock
is telling us that he doesn't have any
plans
uh to resign we're still waiting to hear
from number 10 about their view
uh but it does confirm a breach of the
uh
coveted rules uh he does concede uh that
there is
a a breach of the social distancing
rules uh in how uh he talks about
uh what he has done um so uh that in
itself feels like there's some way to go
to decide
uh whether for downing street to decide
whether or not given the concession that
he broke
uh what they say is the guidance it'll
be interesting to see
whether he accepts that he broke the law
uh concerns downing street enough to
take a different view
but certainly this is a this statement
issued via
the department for health rather than
from downing street uh seems to suggest
that matt hancock wants to stay in his
job
uh it's that bit where he says i want to
remain focused on working to get the
country
out of this pandemic one can only assume
that he's referring uh to
uh do so uh as the uh health secretary
uh he also asks uh essentially the media
uh for privacy
uh uh at this uh uh what he calls a
personal matter
uh he this all comes because he was um a
picture of him
uh uh breaching these social distancing
rules uh so to speak with
uh uh his friend from university uh gina
uh
cola d'angelo uh who was also a
non-executive director at the department
for health was published by the sun
today
uh the picture raises questions uh about
whether or not the activity
was reasonably necessary you can only do
this uh
see somebody who isn't from your
household bubble uh if the activity that
you're looking at at the moment is
reasonably uh necessary otherwise it
would be illegal
no concession about breaking the law uh
but there is a concession from matt
hancock in that statement
that he broke the guidance uh but an
indication that he expects to stay in
the job because he says he wants to help
continue helping fight the pandemic but
not
explicitly saying that he's definitely
safe we wait to hear what downing street
says
in the next hour or so